und dann ganz wichtig sagen wir mal
artig herzlichen glückwunsch unsere
verfassung wird nämlich 70 let's fetz
grundgesetz ja ist doch toll 70 jahre 70
jahre ich sag mal dafür dass die klage
ursprünglich als provisorium gedacht war
hält sie sich ganz gut ne also
jedenfalls besser als die doktorarbeit
von franziska giffey unser grundgesetz
gestern gewürdigt in einer zweistündigen
bundestagsdebatte und während da
irgendeine blondine redet hört man ja
ähnlich zu kriegt angela merkel
plötzlich ihr erstes grundgesetz
geschenkbuch komplott schade keine
bilder drin nur auf dieses grundgesetz
meine damen und herren können wir
wirklich zusammen stolz sein alle
menschen sind vor dem gesetz gleich
vor 70 jahren so verabschiedet vom
parlamentarischen rat ja damals haben
die alliierten bipa nicht nazis die noch
übrig waren so lange in ein zimmer
gesperrt bis sie sich eine demokratie
ausgedacht haben das erfolgsgeheimnis
alkohol jetzt kein witz alkohol jedem
teilnehmer stand pro tag nämlich eine
halbe flasche wein und eine etablierte
während der arbeit am grundgesetz
da hätte alte spruch kein bier vor
artikel 4
und natürlich grundgesetz auf einen das
haut rein
entscheidendes hinterher waren alle
deutschen happy mit ihrer neuen
verfassung alle deutschen nein leider
mit laufen und stimmten 64 mit ja und
109 mit den teilen sich das grundgesetzt
in der vorliegenden fassung hat nicht
die zustimmung des bayerischen landtags
gefunden und deswegen liebe kinder
dürfte bis heute kein bayern ernst
nehmen diese menschen leben nicht auf
dem boden unserer verfassung das muss
man immer wieder wissen hier drin in
diesem buch stehen die unveräußerlichen
freiheitsrechte von 82 millionen
deutschen rechte die bis heute immer
wieder verteidigt werden müssen und wenn
sie das zu pessimistisch finden hier ein
paar heitere umfrageergebnisse rund acht
prozent befürworten sogar eine diktatur
wenn es dem nationalen interesse dient
insgesamt elf prozent einen führer mit
starker hand
damit sind wir eigentlich immer ganz gut
gefahren so der offizielle festakt zum
geburtstag findet übrigens nächsten
donnerstag in karlsruhe statt
organisiert von der verfassungsrichterin
birte schneider
frau schneider am grundgesetz gibt es
wirklich wenig zu meckern oder na ja so
toll dieser alten schmöker ist wir haben
jetzt doch gemerkt manche stellen sind
einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß beispiel
artikel 3 absatz 2
männer und frauen sind gleichberechtigt
[Gelächter]
wer ist nur entstanden weil man den
dummen fehler gemacht hat neben 61
männern auch vier frauen in den
parlamentarischen rat zu holen
kommt gut gemeinte artikel leider
überhaupt nicht praxistauglich beispiel
der neue shitstorm beim adac
grund dafür ist ein foto des neuen
präsidiums dass der adac auf twitter
veröffentlicht hat es zeigt
ausschließlich männer in gehobenem alter
die reaktion des adac hat es nicht
besser gemacht der automobilclub wünsche
sich viele junge frauen die ehrenamtlich
mitmachen
warum geht es frauen immer nur ums geld
traurig nur 8,8 prozent frauen in den
vorständen börsennotierter deutscher
unternehmen
die sind gesetzlich gezwungen ein ziel
für ihren frauenanteil zu formulieren
und da haben 53 von 160 firmen als ziel
tatsächlich 0 angegeben und das ziel
erreicht ja toll darunter auch zalando
eine firma die ohne frauen im jahr genau
drei euro umsatz machen würde so
wir ändern dass männer und frauen sind
gleichberechtigt es sei denn die männer
in einer firma sind dagegen
und was auch leider nicht mehr geht ist
dieses viel zu pauschale politisch
verfolgte genießen asylrecht wenn sie
bedenken welche zustände gerade in
flüchtlingslagern in libyen herrschen
oder auf den griechischen inseln oder
dass es im mittelmeer praktisch keine
seenotrettung mehr gibt dann ergänzen
wir auch sicher politisch verfolgte
genießen asylrecht aber nicht bei uns
sondern irgendwo anders wo wir sie nicht
sehen weil irgendwann ist ja auch mal
gut
es war hart realistisch und zum schluss
das sogenannte grundrecht auf
informationelle selbstbestimmung
aus heutiger sicht geradezu putzig da
geht es um die befugnisse des einzelnen
selbst über seine persönlichen daten zu
bestimmen
[Gelächter]
ich sag nur alexa amazon zeichne täglich
massenweise gespräch mit um das system
zu trainieren und zu verbessern wie es
heißt allerdings können so auch sensible
informationen wie kontodaten an die
mitarbeiter gelangen das unternehmen
erklärte dass die angestellten
abschalten sollen wenn es zu privat wird
und ich bin sicher die machen das sehr
konsequent
+ anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung
staatstrojaner biometrische pass tat
nachweisen was die passage streichen
nummer ganz alexa wir verzichten auf
unser grundrecht auf informationelle
selbstbestimmung alles klar
sie möchten ein grundgesetz verändern
bestellen für nur 999 bitte nein möchte
ich nicht
vielen dank für ihren chef zum
hundertsten mal du bestellst überhaupt
nichts für mich
1 100 gesetze das kann dauern wird so
schneider weiter klickt hier für weitere
heute schon videos und clips
verdachtsmomenten
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]